our teacher would have the textbook up
on like the overhead projector so we
could all see it and I just sat there
she we did like different sections well
I'm a daydreamer so I I kind of zone out
sometimes read the lesson and then we
would get homework always a test at the
end of each section yeah that's how it
was before I used to get it like B's all
the time but since Khan Academy it's
brought me up to an A so that was really
cool the way I use Khan Academy is I do
the exercises and it really helps me
improve my math skills and I watched the
videos if I'm having trouble with some
of the exercises and then I'm able to
get a streak of ten she can see what
you're doing and so if you're messing
around she'll tell you to just do this
set of problems and if you're really
struggling with it she'll help you out
with it if you don't if you don't get
what the video is trying to ask you I
like how it's different than the math
book when everyone's doing pretty much
the same level of things and feel like
higher than it's boring for them and if
they're like lower they're not exactly
understanding it I used to be afraid to
like tell her what I'm struggling on and
now that she can see how we're doing on
the Khan Academy it helps me feel more
comfortable talking to her about what
I'm having troubles with you get to move
at your own pace with it because there
all sorts of challenging exercises and
there are easy exercises and it's really
fun because you can try to get badges
and you can challenge yourself and do
different kinds of math there's meteor
badge wound badge earth badge Sun badge
and black hole badge I didn't really
remember exponents even even though I
did it once I didn't remember it very
much and then I watched the video and
now I know exponents really the guy who
makes himself he teaches the subject
really well
it's like he's probably like writing you
on the computer cuz it shows a little
mouse and he talks into the microphone
and he explains all the subjects in a
way it just makes it really easy to
learn
well my parents just think it's really
cool they think it's a great idea that
we're doing this site
and the good thing is we don't have to
be at school to learn the math we can
just be at home on our computers
basically doing like if it's a rainy day
you can just do it and then you can get
energy points and get badges I really
like it when I finish one of the really
hard ones it's a tool for life everybody
needs to know how to do certain things
in math not just if you're going to be
as unlike an astronomer you have to know
everything one night I was just working
on this my lesson and I just couldn't
finish it and my dad said you can't play
with your friends until you finish that
lesson so and then I finally finished it
because like I watched the video and I
really learned it
you